okay so good morning I'm Ludmilla yonder
and today I'm gonna be talking to you
about teaching data cleaning and
visualization with our inspired custom
sprat scratch blocks so I think that my
talk was scheduled first in order to
ease us into our bursts by starting with
something a little bit more simple so I
work at amplify amplify as a K through 8
education publisher we have print based
online and hands-on materials and I work
on our science team so today I'm going
to tell you about a science unit that
we've developed using scratch blocks to
teach stage data visualization so just
quickly about the team that I worked
with my team consisted of a product
manager a full-stack developer a QA
engineer and a designer and then myself
so technically this work isn't my day
job at amplify I'm a data scientist but
I was asked to join this team to give my
input so what is scratch scratch is a
visual programming interface it was
developed at MIT and it's funded by a
lot of big names and it's especially for
ages 8 through 16 so this middle school
falls really well into that range and
this is what the unit is geared towards
this middle school students specifically
and a benefit of scratch is that since
you're dragging blocks instead of typing
out code you can avoid a lot of syntax
errors and typos which you know plague
us all but especially the early coders
and the blocks can be used to generate
code for a lot of uses that's pretty
impressive actually but at this point
there aren't any blocks for making
graphics graphics graphs sorry there are
any blocks for making data
visualizations grass so here's this
scratch UI there are a lot of blocks you
can see these are just the motion blocks
these blue ones and then all those
colored sections are different types of
blocks and there's kind of a similar
amount of blocks in each section and you
always start with this cat which is
called a sprite
there are a lot of different sprites and
you can give them you can give them
costumes you can create a background and
so on so here's a little example of a
really small thing I made in scratch
within a repeat block I changed the
background I have the cat move 50 steps
and then I have it say hello for one
second this is a gif which is why it's
repeating on a loop I wouldn't do that
otherwise and you can see here that
there's a lot you can do though this is
just scratching the surface of what you
can do a scratch and though there's a
lot you can do as I said you can't make
graphs so we fork the repo and we made
our own blocks in order to make graphs
and work with data so in our work we
really wanted to engender an interest in
computer science and data science and
also make sure that it felt accessible
even especially for underrepresented
groups and to do this we wanted to
create a user interface for data
visualization using scratch blocks and
once we sat down and started working we
realized that we could really draw
inspiration from the tidy verse and the
grammar of graphics in order to achieve
this
so we developed or we're currently
developing a tenday middle school
science unit where students to explore
the EPA's air quality data on the weekly
level for all cities with sensor data in
the u.s. for the year of 2017 so for the
rest of this talk I want to tell you the
story of how these blocks came to be and
show some student work that we've
observed in pilot I want to point out
that while we've moved really far from
this like really simple scratch sketch
that I drew out months ago we're still
very much in the pilot stage so we've
definitely moved past things like I
don't know why I thought we needed to
have some version of pipes right that's
what those orange blocks are things like
that we moved far from here and we have
blocks that you know for the most part
actually work which is really exciting
but worse this is very much a sneak peek
and we're still iterating
really thinking about this really early
stages just want to point that out um so
here we have our beloved central verbs
of the deep liar and the blocks that
we've developed thus far so first we
have the we have filter which we decided
we absolutely needed in the UI but we
change to have an even more explicit
name especially since students don't
have to type this out right so and we're
working with middle schoolers so we've
renamed it to include data if so that it
was super clear what it was and right
now the way we have it is if you put two
include data blocks one after another
it's like an implicit and but we do have
an explicit or we're still kind of
thinking through this I don't love that
but that's where we are right now and
next we have the group I block and
though this at this point the group I
works a little differently than the deep
liar group I which I'll show you in a
little bit it's it's a lot like group I
and so then you can see we have the
mutate and summarize blocks and these
are a little bit hard to replicate in
the UI without good things getting a
little too clunky and we also didn't
really need students to make new
variables so instead we use these
function blocks I don't love that
they're named function I think it should
be something like calculate but this is
what they look like right now and this
allows us to do aggregation and then the
last few verbs select an arranged we
realized we didn't really need them
because students are you know they have
all the variable blocks there and
they're not we do have a spreadsheet
function where you can look at the
spreadsheet version of the data but
they're not using that a lot they're
mainly just using graphs so we didn't
really need select or arrange so moving
onto ggplot which was inspired by the
grammar of graphics by Leland Wilkinson
the kind of general layers in a graphic
are data
aesthetics geometries scales facets
statistics and coordinates so with our
blocks we also
start with the data and then we add the
aesthetics you know what they're X and y
variables and then students can choose
the jion's right now there are four
possible graphs that the students can
make and also students can set color but
we haven't added the ability to facet
add statistics different coordinate
planes or themes so now we're gonna move
into completing a task in our UI using
these blocks so here's a prompt where
students are asked to choose the city
where they live and another city that
they're interested in and compare the
air quality for the year of 2017 so this
is purposefully a little bit open-ended
right we want the students to kind of
play around a bit so they can make
different graphs but there are a couple
things that they do need to do to get at
that information so first I want to show
you the filter block up close and in
action and in conjunction with the or
block so here we're filtering to only
include Los Angeles and New York in the
data and this is what you would begin to
use for the given prompt right first
we're gonna need to filter down to those
two cities and students are explicitly
taught this block a little bit there's a
little activity first before they start
using it so now zooming out I've decided
to make a scatterplot in response to
this prompt so here you can see that
I've set my x and y variables and I've
set my graph type however all the dots
are black so I can't quite answer the
prompt yet so what would I want to add
here just start color yeah Thank You
Brooke so exactly so we can add the set
color blocks and then we start to see
something popping out with this
scatterplot so now we can see that LA
and New York City do follow a similar
trend over the year with worse air
quality in summer but that LA seems to
have more you know higher points which I
think we know to be true in the world
right so now let's say that I want to
make a bar graph instead
so here things get a little bit tricky
at this point we've decided to use the
group by block in order to communicate
that they're two groups should be
identified in this graph it's a little
bit of a cheat it's not a direct
translation from deep liar and it's kind
of like setting color equal to a
variable and then setting position equal
to dodged right so here you can see that
la really does have a lot of higher bars
than New York City especially in the
summer and kind of later in the year and
if I wanted to make a line graph we
would want to do the same group I trick
at this point you know we're still
thinking this through that's where we
are right now so lastly I want to show
you that you can use the function block
within the set x and y block so here you
may be able to see that the students are
actually answering a different prompt
later on where the students not only get
all of the cities but they get all of
the pollutants that are being measured
too which is typically about five
pollutants for some places don't measure
all five and so here I'm just saying
give me the max air quality index value
of you know of all the pollutants for
the city and you'll notice that this is
actually the same as the last graph
because the original data set just takes
that max value because that's what you
really care about with air quality you
want to know what was the highest value
for a given period so I just got back
from observing a pilot of this unit in a
middle school and I want to show you
some of the student work so of course
students made graphs in ways that I
didn't really expect or were different
than what I did here's one that I saw
that I really liked so they didn't make
the scatter plot the way that I did and
but I like this for two reasons one you
can see that there's an issue with our
UI and how we're graphing categorical
variables we really need to move this
over right it doesn't look great that
the first one is getting graph for x
equals zero
but I also think that this is a really
nice graph because you can see that
although the highest point was in
Berkeley a lot of the higher points were
in Atlanta so in general that your
quality is a bit worse in Atlanta
however I do think that this is
interesting they added color but not in
a really meaningful way right because
the cities are already separated out so
the color doesn't really do anything for
this graph so I like this next graph
because the student Peres actually added
color in a way that added a third piece
of information they have looked at the
EPA's guidelines and they made all the
healthy points green and anything above
that they made red so I thought that was
really cool and here they're comparing
Berkeley to Boston so this next graph
shows some students getting a little
crazy and not quite answering the prompt
either since they state instead of City
but I really liked that they added
multiple or blocks they really went for
it they played around with it and that
also made us think that you know maybe
the way that word structuring or blocks
that should look more flat if they're
adding more blocks because right now it
kind of communicates like a weird
hierarchy it looks a little bit strange
so that gave us something to think about
and even though this is a messy
visualization the students said that
themselves they're like whoa this is too
much like so I think that it was a good
learning experience for them to I think
part of this is them making graphs that
maybe aren't the best graphs right
that's part of learning about our data
always um so also we noticed one really
large point that you might be able to
see at the top right corner in
California and we looked it up and it
turns out that it's a real value from a
week that had a forest fire so I thought
that was really interesting that the
students under that so this final graph
is actually answering an earlier prompt
where the student just looked at their
city or the city that they were
interested in and the student actually
stayed after class to add all of these
color blocks which I thought was great
and I want to point out that they
actually use the color scheme from the
EPA so say what you will about this
color scheme
I think it's a really great
visualization right because immediately
you can see that there are only a couple
weeks and this is Los Angeles where the
air quality was considered good and
there was even one week where it was
considered unhealthy so I thought that
was really interesting so finally I want
to show you something that our dev sent
along and asked me to replicate an R in
order to check if ru I was performing as
expected so does anyone want to guess
which graph was made in R versus the one
that was made in our UI call it out yeah
the one on the left someone has some
sharp eyes so it is it's it's the one on
the left but I think it's cool that it's
pretty close and what's even more fun is
to compare all the lines of code that I
used to make the graph in R to the ones
that I to the scratch box right so
granted some of the code at the bottom
is just to make the graphs look exactly
the same I you don't need all of that
but at the same time there is a lot of
necessary deep liar and ggplot code
there in order to get the same graph you
know regardless of looks and I think
that it was exciting that you can see
that even with a small set of blocks the
students can make pretty involved graphs
it's pretty cool and we can really drill
down to specific pieces of information
so in conclusion I want to say that
we're still working but we have a clear
proof of concept that a UI can be built
for students to make tidy verse inspired
visualizations using scratch blocks and
furthermore I think this work is right
for a lot of thought and research around
teaching coding from things like how to
name the block whether they're the order
of the block should matter you might
have noticed that at this point for us
they don't I have mixed feelings about
that and also do you know explicit how
explicitly to teach different pieces of
this and there already is a really good
growing body of research on scratch
blocks and on teaching coding but I
think that this you know could
to that body of research by specifically
adding this data visualization piece and
data science in general and most
importantly I want to say during our
pilot in a pretty diverse public school
I observed a lot of students working
diligently in the UI and really enjoying
their work and they made a lot of graphs
they were able to iterate on those
graphs really easily and spot patterns
and make conclusions based on those
graphs which is really exciting for the
next generation of data scientists thank
you
[Applause]
you